The Joe Rogan Experience
speaking of rock uh you mentioned
WrestleMania 18. yeah and that what's
crazy is that it's one of the greatest
wrestling matches of all time like if I
was going to show you literally and
because I've thought about this because
whatever a decade ago when we would have
our crazy wrestling arguments I always I
had to think to myself well what would I
show Joe first and it would be probably
that
it was a uh definitely a moment I know
the Rock
says he's never experienced anything
like that before I don't think anyone's
seen anything like that it was it was it
was crazy man it was
it was much different than I expected
I'll put it through that way how so
would you expect well I'd been working
for Ted Turner for like 10 years and I
started that NWO thing with Eric
Bischoff and
Kevin Nash and Scott Hall you probably
know who which was WCW the competitor so
we've been trying to put Vince out of
business for 10 years
and we were killing him in the ratings
for like 83 or 88 weeks you know we're
just killing him then there was a
turnaround he brought Tyson on
and we we made a bunch of mistakes you
know programming wise like we were live
live
and their stuff was all taped we go
don't watch Monday Night Raw tonight
because Mick Foley's going to beat the
Rock and this guy yes we'd give him the
finishes just dirty pool you know right
so you need to watch show because we're
gonna tell you he's already gonna win
you know and so
after 10 years with this craziness
um I was pretty much done you know this
was
Hollywood Hogan the bad guy and I had
this crazy run it was just as big as the
red red and yellow around as Hall of
mania was it was just as big or bigger
and so
at the end of the day I was done you
know and uh Ted Turner merged with
American online and where his office was
they kicked him to the curb he was down
at the end of the hall so Ted wasn't in
charge you know and Ted's the one I made
the deal with and Eric Bischoff and
Harvey Schiller and all these guys and
um
so I wasn't I wasn't really going to do
anything I got a call from Vince you
know
he goes uh you know uh we'd like you to
come up and work with the Rock at
WrestleMania I said well yeah I can
still go you know if you need me to come
up there we can make it work and he goes
well you know things he used to call me
monster well you know Monster but you
know things are different now up here
I said what do you mean different and he
goes well you know if you're going to
come up here you got to really bring it
because you know the rocky goes the rock
does this thing and everything like
bring it
and so I didn't say anything as a
smartass I'm thinking if you want me to
bring it you're going to be asking me to
take it back when I'm done with this
[__] so anyway you know we went up
there
had the match there was a bunch of stuff
that happened before the match it was a
little bit different the weeks before
but when we when we when I went up there
what we did on TV was I did everything I
could to be a bad guy
I was in Chicago place was just slammed
in Chicago just crazy
I mean I had so so many matches in
Chicago in the past accolades were so
intense there that when I came out as a
bad guy that people were like with me
you know and so all of a sudden the rock
comes out gets in the middle of the Ring
challenges me to WrestleMania I go to
shake his hand he won't let my hand go
you know he pulls me back in
and right where face facing Rock bottoms
me you know and dumps me in the middle
of the ring on the back of my head so
here come my guys I mean you have to
realize that the this is these are the
most electrical moments ever like in pro
wrestling history the like if you saw it
on video these things this is this is
the epitome of the entire what makes the
entire thing entertaining because you're
kind of rooting for both both are kind
of bad guys but have such likable
qualities so it's a win-win no matter
what I mean this stuff is Beyond like
this is that's this here is like totally
top shelf pro wrestling history I always
loved the two-tone beard must touch
combo yes so anyway after he dumps me on
my head my guys come down Kevin and
Scott and we just crucify his ass we
just we unload on him we just grind him
so I go out of the ring and I got a
toolbox and I dump the toolbox out and
there's this ball peen hammer right
so they got him hooked and I think I'm
gonna hit him from the front I go and I
and while he they got him hooked they
thought I was going to blast you in the
face of the hammer I hit him from behind
with a hammer right I catch him from
behind you know I'm not not killing him
I'm pretty good at what I do is it an
actual Hammer oh yeah
oh yeah bro I can I can put this thing
between your forehead I don't even
please none but anyway it's a
professional no but listen you're
hitting him with a hammer yeah he
actually hit him with a hammer oh yeah
but it's he's a professional yeah I'm
pretty believe me I can hit you with a
hammer brother you'd be good
you know but what yeah no it's a hammer
you know you know who first if she says
he's so good at pulling stuff up pull up
Rock E3 where I get thrown in the corner
I throw that straight in punch to him
okay yeah because he said oh I don't
want to get her I said you just stand
there and don't move well this straight
in punch he goes I've never had anybody
throw a punch it looks like it was going
to kill me
it's
yeah no I think this is it right here
look look look
that was straight into his forehead yeah
he goes you didn't even hit me I said
well I'm not supposed to
but I did make contact so anyway long
story short hit him with a hammer drag
him outside the building put him in an
ambulance put chains around the
ambulance right I go get in a semi truck
without the trailer on just the the cab
of the semi and of course as I'm getting
in the cab with somebody they pulled
rock out of the ambulance
and I and I run that ambulance over with
a semi oh my God this goes do it again
do it again
yeah this is so hilarious so anyway I
had the [__] the ambulance is chained
up yeah
so dude so now the Rock's in there we
just we slide him out when they cut to
me here you go and so at the end of the
day I did everything I could to be the
worst most evil person in the world bad
guy
and we go we go get in Toronto for
Wrestlemania after I've done all these
horrible things oh my God now I had to
back up and run him over again now after
I do all these horrible things
and I come out of the building at
WrestleMania and the place is cheering
me out of the building yeah
I'm going oh my God how are we going to
fix this because the rock is splitting
to go to The Scorpion King and I'm
passing the torch giving him the rub
everything I can to help him be the
greatest wrestler ever you know and
because that guy was so good in the ring
bro
and I never worked him before but second
third generation wrestler Instinct
timing placement he had everything it
took us about seven or eight minutes I
got it all turned back around
you know and he had certain input that
we did and I said well if some of that
stuff doesn't work we're not doing it
you know but it was just the craziest
situation because this is it this is
like the craziest [__] of all time
[Applause]
I mean look everybody's arms are up in
the air
[Applause]
against
Tony is aroused I mean it's unbelievable
you have to realize that these this is
like it to entertain how old were you at
this time
um I know it's 53 or 54. that's amazing
yeah and I had a hip replacement that is
amazing and two knee Replacements that
at 54 you were still this jacked that's
incredible another one another one
WrestleMania 18 after being in one two
three four five and the next year I took
Vince McMahon in Safeco Field
and and actually had a blast with Vince
got to beat the [__] out events that was
fun and heat brought he's all in that
crazy nut was all in he loved it